et je suis d'accord avec monsieur
netanyahou sur deux choses la première
c'est qu'il y aura malheureusement
probablement d'autres attentats en
europe et la seconde c'est que il ya
effectivement une mobilisation globale
qu'il faut avoir pour moi les racines du
mal de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sans
terre chercher très loin et concernent
évidemment tout ce qui se passe au moyen
orient y compris avec l'iran qui
voudraient avoir la bombe atomique et
j'associe d'ailleurs pas ce qu'il s'est
passé hier il ne faut pas l'oublier
l'exécution des chrétiens coptes
d'égypte qui se sont passés en libye
maintenant monsieur netanyahu appelle
les juifs d'europe le répète d'ailleurs
il aurait paix après les attendent il a
dit d'ailleurs très peu de temps après
être venu à paris à la suite de
l'affairé charlie évidemment en tant
qu'européens convaincu député européen
je veux dire ici fermement que les juifs
d'europe et les juifs de france ont leur
place en france et en europe tout
simplement parce que l'europe porte en
elle-même toutes les valeurs qui sont
celles de la tolérance de la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme s'est pas alors
qu'on vient de fêter le 70e anniversaire
de la libération du camp
d'auschwitz-birkenau qu'il faut
aujourd'hui comment dire oublier cela
donc la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
c'est une lutte qui concerne tous les
européens évidemment ici sur je ne me
résous pas je pense qu'il y a des
possibilités techniques et politiques
pour faire en sorte que l'on trouve un
nouvel accord simplement il faut
négocier ce n'est pas simple parce que
je crois que les nouveaux gouvernants
grecque ne connaissent pas bien les
règles de travail en europe ils sont
arrivés un peu comme des chiens dans un
jeu de quilles alors il faut trouver un
accord peut être qu'on ne trouvera pas
aujourd'hui puisque vous savez qu'on a
jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin du mois de
février et que dans ces cas-là on aime
bien jouer le calendrier jusqu'au bout
je fais néanmoins une proposition ici ce
matin parce que il est possible de
trouver une solution moi je dis que si
ça se passe mal aujourd'hui il faut
mettre en place un médiateur quelqu'un
qui puisse être entendu des deux côtés
et qu'ils disent voilà voilà les
propositions sur la table je vous
propose un nom il pourrait y en avoir
d'autres mais par exemple pascal lamy ça
me semble tout à fait convenir pascal
lamy c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
parfaitement toutes les arcanes de
bruxelles il a été le directeur de
cabinet de jacques delors il a été
commissaire européen et 7,1 selon la
presse envers la loi macro comme une
sorte de nouveau catalogue de la redoute
c'est à dire il ya des articles toutes
les pages on sait pas très bien quelle
page on loue vous l'ouvrez à la page
d'ouverture le dimanche une seule chose
me paraît bonne dans ce cas était
décidée ce sont les zones de tourisme
international je pense qu'effectivement
il ya des créations d'emplois possible
dans ce domaine vous savez la loi macro
comme toutes les lois aujourd'hui il
faut les observer avec une seule règle
qu'est ce qui va créer de l'emploi parce
que l'emploi est notre plaît alors dans
les zones de tourisme international oui
et je veux dire là que je trouve
effectivement que tel maire ici ou là et
la maire de paris en particulier qui dit
c'est pas sûr que boulevard haussmann se
ferait ça créerait de l'emploi elle a
tort en tant qu'économie c'est évident
pour le reste figurez vous que je crois
que une canne n'y trouveraient toujours
pas ses canetons parce que c'est comme
avant c'est à dire que vous savez qu'il
ya plusieurs centaines de cas qui
autorise ici ou là les ouvertures de
commerces le dimanche et ça c'est pas
changé et c'est pas parce qu'on passe de
5 à 12 avec en plus l'introduction des
communautés de communes pour intervenir
va tout ça est d'une complexité